so now where am I gonna go from here
this bit again also looks a bit unusual
but noticing from this fork here I'll
just modify its ever so slightly
I probably to be honest don't need to do
this for you to see what I'm not sure
what's the gradient of this line it's -
a on beach right - Manus in there now I
can interpret that in a couple of
different ways this is going to be about
usual we're going to put that minus sign
I'm going to do something a bit naughty
and put it on the denominator that's
very visual but you'll see why in a
second if the gradients - amping right
according to this way of writing it
right gradient is rise over one is it
rise everyone I said even you know I can
leave that up there you'll see what if
rise is that numerator and run is the
denominator okay that means that if I
pick some point on this line any point
um for reasons I'm clarifying that these
things are a matter of separate a little
point I think a point very here and if I
go if I run B units horizontally okay I
don't know what B is so I'm just gonna
draw a line randomly let's say that is
Billy units long okay then if I go down
to the corresponding point back on the
line like this
if I've if I've run B units how far do I
go down I'm gonna go under your - a
right - a that's how far that's my rise
- a and that's fine right B does that
make sense like that's what the gradient
means for any like that good girl I
could go to be across and then I go to -
soon a down that makes sense so what
I've got is I've got some distances here
I've got this being and this being a but
well my diagram I've drawn it downwards
right on another diagram I could just as
easily drawn where it's going upwards so
to try and cover what's going on I'm
gonna say that these are distances so
that's the absolute value and the
absolute value of a are you happy with
that because like if I'd enjoyed if I
draw this line going up then a would be
going the other way if I draw up a like
on the other side of the line it would
also be going the other way right but
all these distances and the Saints just
the sides are going one way or the other
if I take the absolute value I know I'm
right so I've got B here that's the run
I've got in the absolute value a there
that's third that's look rise okay now
this triangle here I also need to do
some work with it
I have a right angle here why is that
because because it's it's its rise and
run once exit one's Y so they've
perpendicular to each other right I need
to be able to talk about this triangle
here so I'm gonna call it I'm gonna name
it t me so now I have two triangles P Q
R and T UV
alright one last statement I'm going to
make geometrically before I actually
start out at my house about them okay
these two triangles are constructed PQR
and tuv they're not red I don't know hey
look at me random but they're not do you
see how not random they are and how
intimately connected they are in fact I
want you to notice that how do i
construct PR I drew it vertically right
which made it parallel to the y-axis
agree I have another line that's
parallel to the y-axis right what's it
what's its name it's UV right this is
also parallel okay now I haven't drawn
them all the way but PR and UV are
parallel lines and they both intersect
with we have we give a fancy name starts
with T when you've got one plane that
intersects in two other parallel but
it's a transversal it transverses across
the two parallel lines so you were trans
sov and you've got two parallel lines
that form two angles you see that what
do we know about parallel lines that
perform these kinds of angles they're
equal what do we call these angles yeah
these ones that I'm putting my face on a
corresponding I did another color so
I've got this
okay you happy with that just so you
really follow it let's actually write
that one down that's reason that's worth
actually including in our in our
derivation okay what are the names of
these two angles I just did
I've got P R cute up there okay and
that's equal to UV t and the reason why
is because corresponding angles now I
could just say parallel lines but since
I know what the parallel lines are I'm
just gonna name them P P R is parallel
to UV corresponding angles are equal you
should say they are equal by the way
because as you know what all pairs of
angles on parallel lines are just
magically equal sometimes a cone terior
okay so I've got all my pieces together
and now I want to work with them because
this angle and this angle are the same
right we're just prove it
I also know that this angle and this
angle are the same two pairs of equal
angles so what does that tell you about
the triangles they're similar
I could draw them so that they were
congruent if I may have like the sizes
match up but at the moment it's kind of
rate and what your sizes are however the
angles are not random at all right so
being that I've got these two one of my
other two angles that are equal
I've got P Q R that's that 90-degree
angle over there and tuv they're equal
because they're both 90 degrees so
therefore I could say that these two
triangles triangle PQR
and triangle TUV they're similar because
they recreate your life you only need
two angles because once you've got to
you've got the third one all right now
in terms of conceptual leaves I only
have to make one more to get to the
perpendicular distance for gun that's it
like all of this what we would have done
like these three lines here there would
have been that course was about ten
lines of algebra okay
what am i after I'm after expression for
D right I'm after expression for D and
what I know is a whole bunch of lengths
like this and some similarity right so
what statement would you make that
brings all of those pieces together
good perfect even corresponding sorry in
similar triangles corresponding sides
are in proportion right in the same
ratio I just pick my science right now
DS the one that I want okay so it's PQ
right
now I need to pick a side in the same
triangle that I will then pair up with
sides of the other triangle so do you
think I should pick like there's two
other sides to choose from
do you think I should pick that one or
that one P or Q R I think I should pick
they are probably because I don't yet I
don't yet know where Q is I mean I could
work it out but it's a whole lot more
effort and I've already determined where
R is okay so I'm going to compare that
with P bar make sense okay so if I'm
comparing P Q and P are what are the
corresponding sides in the other
triangle okay hold on let's just name
the sides first and then we'll find out
what their what their values are equal
to um you can see I've very artfully
named my triangles right so that
everything just lines up in alphabetical
order that's convenient isn't it so
there's a PQ or to correspond to tu
right by the way if you ever wondered
why back in you're eight or nine
wherever you learn similarity Cruz why
do we make you bother to put these
things in the right order and like
assess could you've done well get these
in the right sequence is so that you can
do this part really easily right you
don't even have to look at your diagram
you can say PQ is the first two letters
until you have a post two minutes that's
why they match P R is going to be
corresponding to V T V because they're
the first and last letters right do that
well everything else takes care of
itself
what's that reasoning again for this
line corresponding what
good corresponding science in similar
triangles you can either say are even
the same ratio or you can say are in
proportion they both mean the same thing
okay so now a better statement
this is the last conceptual leap I need
to make now I just need to feel this
that you okay
Pichu Pichu that's this D distance but
I'm after right I might as well do the
work now to get it by itself like make
it the subject that means I'm gonna have
to keep P R over to the other side what
is P R what is Peter um it's this
distance here isn't it right all I need
to do to work out that distance is
compare one y coordinate with the other
one I just want to take the difference
between those okay
now at the moment y1 is on the top right
and minus a X Y minus C on B is on the
bottom at the moment right but I could
just as easily have drawn P so that it
was over here right and then there would
be the other way around it'll be this
minus this so how do I get over the fact
that I don't care which ones first I
just want the distance what do I did is
then I take the absolute value right the
reason why I'm laboring this point is so
that you see absolute value so they
don't just appear because cuz we have to
make it positive there's actually
reasons why I like geometric way it's
like I don't know which one I want
absolute value will give me whichever
one is the right one and that was um
that was pay R which I brought over to
here what's T u it's just be
d or b as in you'd prefer to call this D
yes where did I say D here
that's PQ
because I want to make me the subject
that's where I'm going
okay all right always that once on my
denominator its
TV now I didn't work out what DTV was
before but that's kind of because I feel
it's trivial I have a right angle
triangle here and conveniently my short
sides are a and B so therefore the third
side should be the square root of a
squared plus B squared
cause Pythagoras right so I knew I have
my denominator all right it doesn't just
look like Pythagoras because
mathematicians like Pythagoras it looks
like Pythagoras because Pythagoras is
where it came from
okay now I'm gonna do because I think
you guys can handle it and it's just a
bit of arithmetic I'm gonna do
everything from here to my last line is
you need one go okay
number one I need to multiply through
might be does that make sense so this is
gonna become
by1 right b11 the B's just gonna cancel
here so I'll just get my eggs one of my
seat by themselves that's the first
thing I'm going to do the second thing
I'm going to do is I have to double
negatives here to get rid of see that so
in fact up on this numerator here
everything is gonna become plus sign is
that okay these two become a plus sign
and then these two become plus sign all
right
third and last thing because there are
all pluses I can do them in any order I
like right so I'll put the x1 term first
and I'll put that wire one in the middle
so here's what I get ready this ax 1 on
B becomes just a x1 I don't mean I've
got that be y1 term in the middle and
then I've got that C term hanging off on
the end and I'm dividing by Pythagoras
there okay so do you see how we arrived
there we use some pretty fancy tricks to
get there Wow similar triangles really
complicated stuff no it's not
complicated stuff it's all just straight
lines there's some right angles so
that's why Pythagoras appears one of the
ways that I remember this for because
it's quite a it is still despite how
elegant it is to get there it's still
quite a bit of an awkward formula I
think of the general form of an equation
like that and that's pretty much the
numerator right all I've got is a set of
x and y being some variables I have an
actual point x1 y1 and then the
denominator is Pythagoras and our
neighbor Pythagoras because I think
ridiculous